hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich denke jeder von euch wird
wissen dass ich single bin um mein gott
das war so ahlmann von daher habe ich
mir allerdings gedacht dass wir heute
gemeinsam das spiel table männer spielen
werden da geht es nämlich darum dass wir
unsere tischmanieren unter beweis
stellen müssen in einem date mit einem
mädchen wir befinden uns hier in einem
schönen restaurant ich weiß noch nicht
wer die person über mir ist halo die
bringt ihr gerade und ponys könntest du
die kerze anzünden ich hantiere nicht
mehr mit streichhölzern klar das sind
nämlich unsere aufgaben jetzt ich gehe
mit meiner hand ich einfach mal so ein
bisschen nach vorne über den tisch rüber
greife jetzt nach unten hier ein
streichholz das ist natürlich
selbstverständlich direkt angezündet und
jetzt sünden gibt
[Musik]
dass
ich versuche jetzt mal
vorsichtig mit dem weinglas
richtig greifen
das hast du mich verlassen nicht
verlassen jetzt seht
damals war ein glas meine lieben freunde
ist auch aber gar nicht so wichtig denn
wir müssen die kerze erstmal an das
reine da vorne ist bauer
und können dinge ich es immer so mein
fleisch
lasst uns wein trinken so da oben geht
es für nehme ich packe zwar mein steak
erstmal schön hin ich es aber mit pommes
da zusammen wir wollen wein trinken
natürlich klar erstmal hier so ein
bisschen alles
der wein der wein aber da war ich doch
gleich also den wein bringen wir jetzt
mal ganz entspannt hier
oder wenn sie direkt aus der flasche
trägt ja
okay das war glaube ich nein ich hätte
dir den jetzt mal ganz entspannt hier
ein
höher
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr huber ich brauche neue stars aber
woanders bedeuten
nicht so gehe
die schild am handy sicher so was also
ganz entspannt ist
nein
[Musik]
nein nein nein nein der mine die
wasserschutz und
mein steak braucht noch treffer ich
persönlich bin ja auch ein riesen fan
ich sagte ja immer tempo ist besser als
perfekt
also da vorne steht david pfeffer ich
weiß es nicht toni warum ich dir das
hier auf tun muss ist aber auch nicht
weiter schlimm dafür hast du ja mich so
also erstmal hier nehmen
jedoch ein wo der pfeffer wächst also
hört sich nach oben mit dem verfahren
zurück und abstieg
sind auch hier sehen riechen
guten appetit auf jeden fall bei deinem
pfeffer ding ich glaube sie möchte noch
ketchup zu ihren pommes deswegen gehen
wir jetzt auch mal ganz gut sagt
der ketchup der tochter perfekt gehen
wir ganz kurz runter ach guck mal
können wir eine stunde später
machte ich irgendwas falsch und warum es
bei und links die ganze zeit mit brownie
ich brauche dringend etwas ketchup
ich glaube hier möchte ich so viel zeit
diese ganzen tag zu bewältigen deswegen
konzentriere ich mich ja nur ein
bisschen also die hand nach vorne jetzt
nach unten greifen sollte habe den
ketchup da fließt salz auch raus oder
irgendwas ich weiß es nicht also gehen
da ganz kurz nach vorne bis dann weiter
runter und jetzt ketchup auf steak super
perfect page auffallen lassen gibt es
hier brownies ja natürlich gibt es hier
auch nichts komme ich könnte dir direkt
einen tag nach vorne nach unten damit
braucht man nicht
wir brauchen einen brownie freunde
deswegen runter zu hören und ich ganz
zack da mit dem brownie und jetzt nach
oben und rüber hier kommt fürs vaterland
kleine
schöne sie
gesamtrechnungen
8850 euro ich habe auch starke mann im
hintergrund die ganze diesen ketchup
gießen gehört
es ist das gleiche restaurant mit
allerdings bestellen diesmal auch und
toni sagt auch schon wir sollten
bestellen also was nehmen wir denn ich
habe ehrlich gesagt bock auf eine pizza
deswegen würde ich uns mal eine pizza
bestellen ein bisschen algund noch lauch
das passt perfekt zu mir das bestellen
wir jetzt mal schauen wir mal was kommt
im seminar perfekt das ist direkt da
könntest du uns beide einchecken klar
ein bier für die dame dementsprechend
gehen wir jetzt hier über hoch und
runter
wieso wird das nicht voll mein gott ich
muss meinen die auch noch einen schütte
nach so okay ganz schnell ganz ganz
schnell ganz ganz schnell
weiter nach vorne und kann weiter nach
vorne heute nach vorne so
[Musik]
ich bin klasse a dieses ihrer und das
nervt ist natürlich ist allerdings kein
problem für den mars auch disaster das
hauen wir einfach runter vom tisch
brauchen wir nicht menü sie möchte pizza
und pommes auch noch mal okay bestellen
die post auch noch mal die haben
ich musste alles auf einmal bestellt wir
keine zeit ok zack zack zack beides
kommt hier an sehr gut das habe stellt
sie möchte pizzaessen klar toni du
kriegst deine pizza guck mal hier sagt
gehören
[Applaus]
ist ein bisschen zu wenig gewürzt wird
die menschen zusammenkommen also wenn du
deinen scheiß stück sie will drei stücke
hier ist ein drittes stück
hat sie ihre drei stücke und jetzt will
sie der gewürze drauf haben hier salz
kommen
jetzt fahr oder wie im pfeffer
doch wir haben pfeffer klar war nur ein
scherz toni ich mache alles für dich
guck mal hier sagt der pfeffer auch noch
hier drauf
hat ziemlich hat geschlagen ich möchte
was aber ich bin mir nicht sicher was
okay wahrscheinlich will sie pommes wenn
es daran gezeigt wird deswegen klicken
auch hier auf die pommes drauf können
uns auch die meiner lieben freunde und
die kannste dir direkt rein haniel hat
sie auch später was von mir reinraum
toni
du bist mein renn und alle
nicht nicht wie
ich meine hand nicht
offen
[Musik]
was meldet sich wieder was heißt dass
rechnung was
ich habe es einmal geschafft ihr
komplett durchzuspielen wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihren vielleicht bock
hätte ich vielleicht noch ein anderes
date anderes level anderes restaurant
dann lasst ihn einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da abonnieren einen kanal
und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr dann
den zweiten teil von table männer das
mit luca nicht verpassen wollt schreibt
in kommentare was eure komischste date
geschichte ist vielleicht hat ja auch
noch nie ein date so wie ich
aber egal
nicht immer alles klappen obwohl
bei mir
irgendwie fit sind ich vielleicht
mittlerweile überhaupt mal ingos klappen
sollte im leben